a lot of viewers have been reaching out
to us about housing issues landlord
problems and a whole lot more one
property the eight news now
investigators have shed light on the
Apex apartments near Twain and Cambridge
Vanessa Murphy has more on why some
tenants continue to demand answers
for the most part the property here at
Apex Apartments appears to be cleaned up
but most of the units are also boarded
up much of this looks like an abandoned
building
I get it there were low-income families
but we don't deserve to live like this
you know we pay our rent the CarMax are
one of the few tenants left here at the
Apex Apartments there are seven
unbordered Apartments still
california-based pro-residential bought
the property in January of 2021 and has
been operating without a license since
then still collecting rent money and
covid-19 rent relief money the county
sued the owners pointing to dangerous
living conditions and a major spike in
crime including murders on the property
judge Jessica Peterson has given the
owners several chances to clean the
property up many squatters are gone
trash is picked up and security
intermittently walks the property but
the CarMax say while this may appear
nicer on the outside inside there are
still problems there's just wires
hanging from our ceiling that these
cannot for seven or eight months people
were using the laundry rooms for drug
use prostitution all that stuff so then
they'd board them up and just took them
away while the future of the property
remains unclear they say they're hoping
for answers from management and Clark
County the only information that we
found out is we keep finding the news
stories the next court date for Apex
Apartments here is set for November
reporting in Las Vegas Vanessa Murphy 8
News Now now we reached out to an
attorney for the Apex Apartments this
afternoon and did not receive response
in time for this broadcast